shake it out shake it out oh my god mom
we're gonna do another shots is a good
doing it right now doing another one and
we're doing it there's Kevin Farley over
here with them yeah Pat fan we do in the
house and this lovely abode thanks for
coming yeah the trance oxide or so I
don't know if we're interrupting your
day I don't know no not at all I uh I
was gonna give a table read this
afternoon I do that's so gnarly so
Hollywood oh yeah I'm table read so I
can't stick around o dinheiro just
walked by give a giant glass window here
okay sorry okay you can move them along
the metal to see here fine exactly I
love the middleman in that angry sir we
got right yes I do now it's a great show
i mean neil flynn is available and it's
just great second city great actor and
Patricia Heaton is uh is awesome he's a
snow lady so cool she said nice things
about the the documentary sweetest
tonight oh really sure that's that's
really cool we did um it's funny I Brian
Murray who's from the same parish as i
am from back in Chicago which always
when I say that I all right not in New
Orleans but yes Brian doyle-murray whose
second or third up by the nine Murray's
and yes so his mom and my mom used to go
to church every day together at st.
Joe's in Chicago and we're sitting there
was Patty Heaton and Brian and I talking
and we got on the subject of both of
them have sisters that are nuns yeah I
sister does yes and brian has a sister
sister Nancy who taught my little sister
Katie but I'm like this there's no other
triad in awe yeah I'm gonna say the
state of California is talking about
that's the only girl right yes
Susan done wow she does yeah yeah you
just don't see nuns anymore it's true
yes where'd they go right I don't know
listen I grew up with them they're all
over the place I grew up with them there
or there was a ton of ladies that wanted
to be none yeah nowadays they don't even
want to do it I don't know why I mean
it's not a bad gig when you think about
it let's say everything down there is
kaput right uh let's see you medically
speaking folks this is also a medical
college you reach an age where you're
like okay it's done you know that's done
Kevin did it happen oh yeah it does no
no I think you just there's a certain
group of the population where they reach
a certain age you're like I don't even
want to do that I mean they don't even
have a libido to do it so then you go to
the church and you get meals you get a
car you get you know everything taken
care of I mean not a bad gig it's not a
bad game no I I think nowadays too when
our kids I mean used to the nuns to be
honestly I would you feared them that
was somebody who would you know they
would scold oh you'd be in trouble and
my dad grew up in Greece and his he's a
left-handed guy but he's right-handed
because the nuns oh right cuz he was the
only man that was one who is he was a
witch at the time he was yeah we a lot
of Greece which so which are kind of
cute I like you let's gonna smoke poof
why there was always the really nice
none yes no yeah there was a there was a
good handful that we're pretty angry but
then they made up for one really nice
one yeah I you know it's funny our
daughter at the time our oldest daughter
Cassidy when we moved out here we didn't
know where to go to school we kind of
fell into this school st. Francis de
Sales here in the valley and good school
yeah if I can plugs with these great fen
ya know ya where you know I do know that
but it's similar the one I grew up in
but I remember meeting the principal at
the time who is none and just being like
you know instantly hands in a party I
contact I know there's a ruler abilities
go back to that I did
she's amazingly nice and I was so mean
be like even think it's just PTSD that's
all I guess yeah religiously yeah it is
funny they're nice though they're really
not nice lady I went and um she's in a
home down in newport and i found through
the friends if grapevine or whatever
that she needed a bookshelf to how she
likes to book good read books and all
right which is weak podcast I so she
gave me all the dimensions I made it for
and I went down and oh my god drop it
off and just kind of say hi and they
good to see you again and I go to Mass
this week and I won't feel bad and I SAT
and talked with her for like four hours
oh that was great but she had a book on
her um desk about Kennedy she's reading
about Kennedy in the family and
politically super intelligent yeah right
this is so cool so somebody that should
be out you know how many kids are doing
a podcast yeah but it was me I think
your point they are well I always look
at it I think you're I reached a certain
age where I go God my mom and dad were
strict now that I reach a certain age
where I go I was a dick swim in it wait
a minute I look back it was like you
know you reach that age we go you start
to look at it objectively and you go oh
yeah well I stole a car you know or I I
was talking in class not supposed to
yeah no I mean ego the nuns are at the
nuns are [ __ ] no no you were a dead
you would be bad you know and a lot of
these guys that look back at cabbage
school anything like whoa what did you
do what were you doing yeah right well
she got out of the blue hit you with a
ruler I mean that was it for where you
[ __ ] around well if you came helmet
Saigon done hit me it was like uh-oh
what did you do that was so egregious
all right let the next person to god we
did it this is on the parents used to
side with an of course what are you
gonna do there yes yeah
now the parents are like that nuns wrong
ya know the kids change I agree yeah I
can yell at him we had a this there was
a nun at our school called sister her
name was sister ray Fellini she was very
sweet art and there's a kid no in class
I just call him Dennis cuz he's probably
listening he's got a red hair yesterday
and Dennis was the one you knew that
would probably end up doing time he's
just a lot of trouble his little Dennis
the Menace admits if you just named him
it's just a name yeah you knew this was
a kid who's not and on the right path
and Dennis we're sitting there and we're
in a hard class and I don't know why he
turned to me and he kind of feared this
kid he turns because he got my sister a
flame and pretend like you're talking
was a guy low that's not two cats come
on man it's not come on do it be
hilarious the whole class of laughs I'm
like well if there's laughter classroom
Mike that's my kind of my night Roland
by real ha and this is awful but I am I
went up to her and I choose very tall
I'm very big and very nice but I tapped
her on the shoulder and I sat down
sister ray Pauline and then she nears
Patrick and I looked at her and I
mouthed things with nothing coming out
and I was like like this like an idiot
and everyone's gigan and I kid you not
this day she stops and goes oh okay oh
by the way and she took her fist as hard
as she could punch me in the throat wow
you're not and she go she goes when
you're fooling around with somebody
who's deaf and you're pretending to talk
your voice box moves and mine didn't so
she knew that I was just making a puppet
down and it was but it was instant
justice that was it I there's no call to
the parents there was no and it was like
I was sore for a week and rightfully so
I was me silly nobody's not crazy
what happen if Dennis sure it was like
Dennis [ __ ] put you up to it you did
yeah but it was so I was I was it's
exactly what should have happened yeah
like no it's over it's over for you gosh
probably like six or seven degrees of
make that well she must not have punch
to do heart because that could collapsed
your larynx right but it was still no an
ain't a nun just hard to hit me guess it
wasn't like she went to you know I had
billy blanks and I was Irene in third
Thank third grade remember frito Bandito
erasers hot consider the frito Bandito
erasers so I just got a new it came used
to come in Fritos I think yeah and I had
Fritos at lunch and I call this thing is
cool and I'm playing around with this
thing and I'm like I had a couple of
them on my desk and I was gone I am a
free today is the song yeah I am a frito
Bandito then they let it live it and I'm
playing around with it completely in my
own world and this eraser comes out I
see it coming out of the side of my you
know peripheral hits me right here in
the side of the face and I look dazed me
and was chalk all over my face and the
sister Mary she discussed hey pay
attention stop playing with your friday
that's elimination yeah all over my face
and every one of the kids like that's
the way the head of the judge she just
took the eraser and goes hey right
[ __ ] threw it at me and hit me in the
face like god damn ok sorry but then
you're kind of like most people wouldn't
have that kind of accuracy and like like
the nose when you cross the right she
threw the racer come on hit me in the
face in chocolate oh my face what were
you doing at without again playing with
a frito Bandito going i am afraid of
auntie does it leave it she's trying to
teach class just hurled the thing at her
other thing at me oh god yeah but I mean
Chris tortured nuns to the point of like
ridiculous I mean you know I mean the
funniest I think I told us at the
documentary where we had a sister Rosa
who used to do the whole penguin thing
like yeah you know the full dress full
dress and she taught math
and she was probably 60 something she
had tiny little round glasses you know
you something out of the 18th century
picture that you see she's coming out of
the mathroom chris is barreling down the
hallway as fast as he can even in high
school he was around two hundred two
bills and fast and fast fast when he got
going it was like a grizzly bear you
know and he's coming down and she just
[ __ ] comes out of the bathroom and
they collide and I swear to god she just
the whole thing ten feet in the air
habit everything comes off Oh not around
slides on the floor like he hit her so
[ __ ] hard and everybody scattered
their thought Oh Farley is dead ya he's
dead and he got like all months of
detention did he help her dude I mean
barreled into this not Harold that's
just one of those how did these glasses
get all the way to the captain is mr.
blindsided some blindsided her god
[ __ ] hilarious I love it yeah he
would do that that's the kind of trouble
he always got to know you know right and
that wasn't even like a premeditated he
was probably just like I gotta get to
class or I'm late right go to the
bathroom I didn't mean it wasn't like
yes this was any way I could take out
some sort of a he's just the way you and
him both had the cudi commonality of
never getting into trouble of like the
trouble you guys got into it was never
from a motivation of a hey let's steal a
car or something no it was nice of
motivation trying to get somebody else
to laugh yeah and then it would get all
bad then you get into trouble yeah
wasn't it was never any malicious let's
hurt that nurse not do something bad
let's touch whatever and yeah they I
think that it's yeah we won Chris in the
same door how did you guys first meet we
met uh we were actually in the same dorm
I I applied to school my mom wanted me
to go out east so I proud to school
called fair you had another school you
were gonna go to Fairfield was a school
in Connecticut yeah you really went
because they are holy cross and so I was
all set and I'm like I'm gonna go there
and
and I ended up not getting in and I was
like I was ours man I can't believe it
blah blah blah and it's like August and
my mom's likes what are you dude I was
five out of six kids she's everybody in
the kitchen what are you would he go
where'd he go to school okay I'm just
going to mark at what okay did you tell
him you going there yeah I applied and
got in so I'm in and she's like if you
have to tell them you're going there
because they don't know you're to say
rumor i literally just stuff just a
sheer like red phone my god i called him
up and they're like yeah we're sorry man
there's no room oh so you were late to
say i want to go ya like like now like a
week before school kind of a thing no I
had a call my brother knew this guy
named father wall she was the head of
communications or something so I call
him yeah there's a pattern auto filled
up there son oh my baby want to go no
you do lots of people want to go ahead
i'm now be English but it was own he was
very European yeah he literally was like
are you gonna work hard and do all your
stuff and he got me in oh so I stayed in
the lounge at Schrader oh really like
you didn't have a room no I the milan i
was in all you working at yeah they were
wats one of them was Brent oh oh my god
why was Brett on a cot he um he didn't
think he was going there because he was
gonna go to Tulane and then my god um
wow he realized that he couldn't afford
too late and so he was like pulled the
trigger and he did the same thing he
last minute kind of went there oh wow
I'll tell you a quiz were both on the
couch yeah so they literally had like
these for army cots yeah not comfortable
you were you on there for a while man oh
you beyond a couple of it was like a
little mini prison it was like a no or
not like master though no probably
probably 3-4 weeks maybe we get a phone
oh yeah as a long coat we had to wait
for somebody to get sick of marquette or
kicked out or tired of it or not show up
by a lot of kids got sick right away
because it's it back then it was pretty
dicey area it was yeah I mean Milwaukee
yeah you're in the middle of Milwaukee
and it's it was not good and then winter
starts come along and it gets dark right
but so I mean if you noticed
so I meet theirs for cots and there's
this guy Mike Brennan who turns out i'm
the same own dad and Buddy be has since
become a roommate and amazingly dear
friend to to Kevin and I and so there
was another guy and his name was
Christian and Christian was a little bit
older than us because he was trying out
by the ski team and the US Ski Team and
all this stuff and all good athlete yeah
he's probably like 20 so he's a little
bit more older than us lemoore mature
yeah and so we're sitting there in Chris
you know Mike and I would just play
cribbage wouldn't they know anybody's
we'd get like a six-pack of natural
light and put it this bad cuz that
styrofoam and no ice gonna remain the
awesome temperature we go hilaria series
two guys take it out in the middle of it
my kids love is it's like a pregnant you
can be an art installation yes so I
would you go to the bathroom or anything
you gotta go to date I mean they made
mad right yeah yeah and my mom like move
me and she gave me like a sheet that was
wrong side didn't she give me a towel
that was like the one we used to wash
cars they could dry them off my car wash
Towson I couldn't find any other towns
it was like orange rolls in remember the
first time day in question about the
shower I walk down this hallway and it
was me in my you know I was working on a
7 up truck so I had farmer tan ok so
it's white with farmer tan I got this
orange hole filled towel and I like a
bar of soap that's it and maybe like
some like a holiday in getting
shampoo-conditioner combos she'd grab
mom and I'm walking to the to the
bathroom yes I kop dopey dope and out of
now it's slow motion and now it's like a
John Hughes movie the door opens and his
sophomore gets out and he's got a satin
robe and he flips up his hood just black
satin robe and it says Motor City Cobra
was down John Bergman and then he
reaches over and grabs he's got a boom
box in one hand to go up 28 feet he's
got a boom box and he grabs like a
corona six-pack bottle holder
no puzzles but he's got all his product
in there for his hair and everything and
he starts walking and girls are like
just like just unbutton her shirt and I
just like my tiles falling off and awful
so wax at I know so um so uh so anyways
were there and Christian wasn't super
happy with us you know we were
tomfoolery and and he it was a serious a
very serious very serious academically
he's like I went up this is my i'm
reading the first chapter of every
single book we were like we i'm not even
that you're reading it you got books hey
like you already got a baby John elbow
like the lilypad jumping and anyway so
he was a tennis player making a tennis
and there was the fourth guy his name
was Matt and Matt never we every day
when I got Matt never showed up so we
always run it when I got a nerf hoop
when we put up liking on the mat is not
same with soy so we're like Matt's wife
memorial gym at 30 max like memorial
cooler Matt so accruals you know for a
good time Matt cut you know what I all
this dump start hey so Loftus one time
is hammering you guys hey I've got to
get in here we're going here your room
and pretend I'm Matt's like I like oh
that's awesome so he came in Hammer
messed up his hair you had no shirt on a
leather coat two bags and he kicks the
door open he goes I'm at site in which
two ronnies like what's with all this
crap and we're like any boats is pointed
a Christian as a guy and he's like I
didn't do it these guys did it they're
always messing around you're blaming it
on me he's gonna dicks I don't what
they're talking about I'm freaking I but
not he went nuts so he went nuts so I'll
just finish this guy's got a soap he
leaves storms out and then he he comes
in and he's like you guys I'm sorry i
just made an emergency request I'm
getting out of here I'm I'm getting out
he's a quitting yeah again it wasn't
like we were bad or whatever tonight
you're just joking it's like fine go to
some other dorm go wherever and the next
day i'm down at lunch and so i'm sitting
down and brento and a couple other guys
and Chris comes in it was
are you guys doing hey man what's going
on nothing less um hungover home my
guitar I was gone with Dylan's was last
night blah blah blah and he goes oh you
know my roommate started going crazy on
the top bunk and he starts kicking me
he's going hey oh you're peeing on me I
guess I was peeing on I'm gonna make a
most people don't wake up and just
randomly accuse people but I was just
testing you and he goes so he kept
kicking me so I stopped peeing and I
woke up and he goes ah jumped off the
thing and I landed on his tennis racket
and he freaked out and he left and that
was Christian he got transferred from
our um lounge to Crispo how crazy I
could you imagine you just went to the
top of a mountain son of light it up he
got a perm and commuted so he had to
have left right after that date he
actually ran for like guy various vice
president treasurer I would vote for him
and I would say hi to him yeah but he
got a perm and he transferred like for
an hour and a half away he drove from
his parents house and he drew anyway
enjoy a good Christian and he would just
his eyes were like and he would go
immediately the other way and follows
sorry about the wreck no I get it like
Chris I think went through almost like
whatever six of those guys he did he
went when he first got into Marchetti
was marked you know uh McCormick hall
and you got assigned a he got assigned a
guy he must have gone through five or
six of a maybe you know and then finally
they said you just keep it yourself yeah
just to achieve that yeah you got a
single by got a single by himself it was
we went in there and it was so trashed I
mean yeah when I would go see I was
coming in after you know two years after
Chris and I would go like I visited one
time and I remember like I guess I'll go
to Marquette cuz chris went there I mean
I didn't know what the relic I wanted
not yet so I visited one time is a
senior and I went out with her ball
Chris and a bunch of other guys in his
group and we went and did you know all
that we went on the east side of town
you don't go on the east side of more
you say I think that's you know it's
going to the east side we're gonna go
down to the National liquor bar all this
[ __ ] and we I remember being in the back
seat of the car that I think her mo was
driving and thinking to myself this is
it I'm dead yeah i thought fuss and I'm
dad I'm in the darkest place I've ever
been in my life wasted and then like God
then thinking to myself what the [ __ ] is
this school this is out of control you
know and then I go okay I'll go there
I'll go yeah yeah no I got in her mo had
a car and there were times it was like
you get in the car and they hear all
this bottle I got to start the car I go
all right that's rather responsible of
you know but you're right you'd go to
the National liquor bar in your country
I'd may be any later became a doctor
yeah I'm a doctor may I Steamboat
Springs it does a really good guy does
Doctors Without Borders great doctor ya
know he was one of those guys that could
be later he'd be like partying and then
he'd be like I'm done yeah you know and
then stop you know you'd be like oh well
we were all gonna burn it and go crazy
and he would just stop and be
disciplined and then you know get a
[ __ ] a you know I ever gang you know
he's just one of those guys yeah but I
remember Chris like Chris's rooms were
notoriously like his dorm rooms were
just like a tornado you know yeah why I
[ __ ] on my mom made a call
servicemaster which is like the ship
that you people come in after murders
and [ __ ] like fiction yeah i'm bringing
in the wolf yeah yeah the cleaner but
these guys had like full-on like you
know mass flamethrowers and buggy and
yeah and they would go in and my mother
back get the servicemaster in here
include yeah but it was just puke in the
corner poop everywhere I don't you know
who know but it was it was it had that
kind of pig pen or about it like with
tonight but there are times you'd walk
up like what's up bar I was gonna go
okay and you like Hayward your door go
just things i got i don't know look I
can't keep contract track of all these
things that's your door you have one
yes metal door unhinges one of my
favorites trader stories of chris is he
uh was eating tuna tombstone pizzas yeah
and he was it it's he will do this
terrible story he would he was I think I
might have told this man telling him i
told this on the pocket i think i know
where it's going she's my favorite story
cuz in mark addict it's really sub-zero
I somebody told me this maybe it's a
myth I don't know but he said but I do
know that he used to eat out with his
belly to eat pizza you know without a
shirt on and he'd have it on his belly
and just be eating it like this and he
put it out of his thing put it on his
belly and was so [ __ ] hot i got Matty
like ah [ __ ] thing was hot you know the
tombstone so he opens up the window the
Schrader and he's like on the eighth
floor and just girls pizza out the
window you know and goes [ __ ] this
goddamn things hot and in the mid air
the top of the pizza okay mom revealing
the nuclear hot tomato cycle because
that tomato sauce is like Nick hot
really blocking out the Sun and it goes
through the air like this for like five
seconds and chris is watching it he just
realized he just let it go and it wraps
across this girl's face he's on the way
to the library and scalding hot tomato
tombstone pizza all over her face and
she's good and chris was so excited that
he had hit her that he stood out the way
to an i got her and she nailed him in
trouble cuz he's he gloated after right
yeah yeah I didn't mean you in the
beginning he decided about the out about
the outcome hilarious you know cuz God
oh how it hurts so bad so you know she's
gonna library doesn't expect me hot
steamin do I don't pizza dude ready
baby's new scar I just gotta push whoa
what is that out of nowhere I don't know
where you know but marquette was fun in
those days goddamn we had a lot of
shaders
Kim no that's McCormick trader was kind
of a crossing that was like a 10 story
was great and that was koed so that was
a little more yeah yeah yeah and but I
mean we used to also they don't have
this now is block party you know in the
oh yeah so fun we didn't have a football
team so you know our football team we
used to play thinner and I and Chris
would play rugby which was great but we
didn't have a football team so our
saturdays they were just like a [ __ ]
show you started drinking it like friday
you know it early yeah and then you were
drunk tell Santa clear night and black
party was three days or no two days
where all the beer companies in and
Milwaukee would converge on Marquette's
campus and have tents yes set up fine
and you would just go from tent to tent
to tent and hit up here and they all
want you to like well you know be you
should be loyal to our beer cuz it was
three breweries in town and these trucks
gonna pull up and they were like cows
but with beer utters yes Crockett's just
had like four on each side and the truck
was in the middle it wasn't like we'll
just use this side it was like no they
use both sides and it would say come on
let's go and they would just constantly
just put beer down Wow it was just the
whole campus with the whole campus
whether your nerd or band guy I don't
care you were [ __ ] blacked out
everybody was [ __ ] up it had it was a
huge huge part remember Rolling Stone
when I was maybe a junior came out with
various thing best food on campus best
you know ban whatever Marquette was most
bars per capita yeah and I can't I walk
by nine bars to get to my class like
what is going to get you on the way
there the way but something's gonna have
you only say no so many times I you want
to be
actly he had the biggest export of the
city oh god it was we were quietly I
think one of the biggest party schools I
think quietly because you know ASU those
guys hell pretty flashy but Mark had I
would put anyone any one of the guys I
was in school with I'm against any any
school anytime we would go to other
schools like we were gone rugby trips
and and we just blow them out of the
water yeah why is that get passed out
like maybe on such another level yeah
and these guys really yeah we're a party
school we know how to party and we come
in and [ __ ] it they would be like wow
Your Honor way to say hey animal nobody
else is like okay you win yeah right
when the party guys go oh yeah you guys
guys know well that's not partying
that's you guys are going on another
level that's crazy you were gonna lose
money raised yeah he's insane we go to
Notre Dame you know I mean Notre Dame
you know we played Notre Dame and rotary
leave older lane the thing is the
biggest thing with our rugby team is the
party you know it was an unwritten rule
that the hosting team get a half barrel
and have a party and Notre Dame's about
I don't know 23 our driver walking
something like that so in a long so long
were like wow drive all the way down
there got our asses kicked by these
super athlete notre Reine guys
everybody's on over everybody's hung
over and we get our asses being in and
then we're like I you guys said I
where's the wears a hat bro no hey
what's up yeah and they're like um no
half hour uh no we don't do that like
wha you stuck a drill falls away yeah
we're stuff in South bad ball [ __ ]
hell never drive back uh I was proved by
remember we I did one we had a game up
at Carthage College which is um kind of
off our campus yeah and we played it was
like West Virginia or maybe lives in a
tournament now I think was in I think it
was West Virginia and they drove all the
way there and i've been in some of the
worst neighborhoods in milwaukee
cago New York I've never been more
fearful of these guys that came out of
his van and waving the Confederate flag
and Apollo yeah I remember kind of going
um not to be whatever we won that war
but you guys lost the world you guys are
all in one in your own country and
you're waving the flag yeah hey I'm not
i mean that with anything we should be
right but it is these guys got bottles
of moonshine and we're kind of getting
ready for the game rises in milwaukee in
milwaukee like 11 in the morn in their
own van yeah and they and they dig
another they all came up with like
bottles of nondescript no label like a
moonshine like you can put your comb in
it all over the barber shop and just
shocking it and you're kind of like hey
well I had 74 beers last night but I
think that's a problem sharing some
weird crap and we've got a game in 10
minutes and it's disrespect but we win
and they were as another drunk rain we
got I mean which was actually easier
because you kind of just push them aside
because the coordination is on the right
and then they didn't go to the party
because they'd all passed out Wow Oh
horrible yeah Mike Oh more ferocious for
the gas to get hit miss the 15 for the
games oh yeah yeah that's okay so they
win they win they went out number one of
um we had which chris i don't know you
see you would have to have elections
which is always kind of amazing to me
that you know rugby players are a little
bit like pirates yeah organized under
some umbrella but they're also still i
will say that the general thing is they
don't really take to authority right I
almost to the person yes to the rugby
player really doesn't like authority if
there was a dad and his two sons and
they saw oh there's a bunch of guys from
the football team let's go say hello and
wish him luck this if you said there's a
buncha guys for the rugby team you
wouldn't run across the street to grab a
picture
rafid be like that's the exact opposite
not that we were bad guys cuz Matt Foley
who ended up is a freedom but i will say
there each one was a character in and of
themselves yes in other words their own
little country yeah you know and each
each rugby player had its own
personality and didn't they played on a
team but yeah they had distinct
personnel very much so yeah there was
some great Bob Ward who was my ta in at
marquette in English Sonia he would he
would remember the first thing I do here
I gotta see and my come on man that was
kind of good he's a gay just cuz we're
on the team together doesn't mean you
get a's I'm like oh no I mean if it's
good i would assume I did something
decent and he just rode me all year and
such a bad story there so we get to the
end it's a final paper and I'm like
looking right now right now I've got
like a stay at Marquette they had a a B
C for some reason and because it used to
be a music school no I'm Jay Z so um so
I'm right now getting a CD or D all
right forget it and I knew one of the
guys who took the class last year and I
said give me your paper would you get on
it i got an a- great give me your actual
paper and i'm going to write my name on
top and I'm gonna tell him but I'm
waiting for him to tell me what my grade
is so I handed it in and I said hey Bob
were at a party at the butt out in the
kitchen and I go would you get in that
great and I met on the things I want to
talk about school and I just one oh my
god because I gave you a c-minus I go
okay cuz by the way I think you riding
me hard and a couple of the rugby
players were like yeah whose paper was
at and I said office own toes and he
goes what are you talking about I said
you know just you know I did word for
word that paper put my name on it and i
got an a- last year so you're riding me
gave me a C minus Anita and then he then
he turned into the plagiarism side of it
that I didn't see coming early oh that's
true that is illegal and I've broken the
code of the school right all right yes
done in
pardon me I could be kicked out so we're
all kind of sitting there now it's
become instant yeah what's gonna happen
is we're in the kitchen and it's four in
the morning so I had to eat things as a
gag like I would have give me gains
burger and I'd eat it ah ha ha said I go
hi all eat something he goes with what
did you get me your grade and he goes I
was gonna give you addy and he goes now
since that paper came up i'll give you
up i get a CD and i said i said i think
i deserve at least a B and he goes
you're not getting one and I said what
what if I what if I eat five raw eggs in
a glass Oh bro and he goes uh no and I
was like oh when you go from there yeah
and I sets a good good bargain and he
goes you like eggs and I said no but I
can eat him raw and he goes you know
what eat a ride with the shell no no
yeah and I had read somewhere which were
a lot that I would be that's what I said
he goes for a b-minus I go no straight
upbeat and then we ended things drinking
like you know it deserves me it's like a
mini supreme court all of a sudden
without the road if the president
Marquette heard this baby so damn it is
a crummy ring out of the valedictorian
goes I'm just eat an egg I read
somewhere that you can learn egg and
safe as long as you chew it and it's an
amazing amount of protein so it's
actually okay so I ate the whole it's
crazy it sounds really weird but I ate
the entire egg everyone cheered and I
gotta be we're gonna be the [ __ ] it is I
know and every dick I was gonna get d-
at best how do you do it like you take
all of one yeah it's kind of a starburst
read it but if one of your kids goes
home I mean what are you gonna say like
Cassidy would you guys at kezi you know
got a nap on that and dead you ate an
egg crazy don't matter that not exactly
you can get a round thing you thank you
for Abby yeah Oh God yeah well then you
should be able to bargain with with uh
with stewed with teachers back at
marquette I I bargained with my
accounting guy he goes he goes you're uh
you're um you're really dumb yeah I went
into his class then he goes yeah you're
not you're not gonna make this class
you're mean back then they didn't care
like I meet my finance he's like am I
gonna pass he goes oh oh no no well if I
don't then I'm kicked out he goes burnt
then you're kicked out I mean they
didn't care it's a different but then
you would go like all right [ __ ] man
come on like you could talk to him and I
remember saying to the guy go dude I
can't do this thing goes all right I'll
bargain with you here let's go you know
and he would make a deal with me where I
come in and work with him a little bit
or if I gotta see on the final he'd give
me a D and pass or whatever you know he
just he wouldn't you could bargain with
a little bit but hey if you didn't go in
and see him then you're dating him [ __ ]
yeah I think it as long as you were kind
of like goin yeah you go in right
hustles face-to-face and they do I mean
they'll sad with Chris and I they were
just kind of like I just moved the train
along just get out of here I know there
is yeah cuz everybody always ask chris
did get his degree he did did ya did he
did I don't know how but he did I mean
Haiti Murnane help them all he did I
mean he was in classes we have
communications classes it was like half
the rugby team half the basketball team
my brother Mike Regan yeah like but
Chris I always remember crisp Chris's
whisper was always louder than most
people's don't don't don't turn the page
back like was so loud when you try to
tease her at st machine yeah i remember
he took this girl's chair actually
wouldn't like she gotta speed it up like
it is a teacher like reading the
newspaper like what's going on is a girl
can't she'd scoot up away from him and
then Chris would follow her mmm and then
I don't know many bumper cars you can't
go back
since and then Chris would scoot his
sideways and with each over and pull the
arm of her desk around Oh to the point
where she was almost completely turned
on but the look on her face like she was
on the worst teacup ride at Disney were
you doing why am I being a turned around
I can't see like that and then it was
always followed by like because you have
an extra pen now i'm giving you supplies
God but it was I caught him on the way
to class I used to study cuz I was like
[ __ ] yeah you have business yeah I am
you know business school now and I
caught him on the way to class I was
coming out of business school and he's
got his Budweiser coat on and he's
smoking a joint and he's got a pencil
and a piece of paper you know anything
you know that's all he did when he took
the class I go what the [ __ ] what are
you doing he goes I'm gonna pull out and
I go what are you gonna take wait what
are you are you taking he takes a hit
out of the things philosophy and then he
just walks in he puts the joint out like
a cigarette and then walk yeah like if
they were like CSI and you like I had a
camera on campus and they just kind of
just pervade all of the students and
professors walking about and then just
when hold on stop on that everybody else
has books everyone else has backpack no
one else has glasses and a vision to
what they're doing this guy looks like
he's just look he lost his ab it was a
few of kris is kris like guys like
Queens was I was always like he's this
is yeah but I mean Queens I think had a
job lined up after school because he
could not give a [ __ ] about studies or
anything like that and I remember he was
another guy that was just completely out
of hand he was on our rugby team and he
would get drunk and I remember I yelled
out the window I'll never forget this i
was at the butt house and I yelled out
the window it was Queens and poot
walking down the street and they were
blacked out [ __ ] up and then you know
out of control and I knew they're out of
control and I wat on my window I go hey
get off the street you bums you know
like like get out of here
we're drinking on Saipan you bums I read
something in Queens cuz he luxurious
[ __ ] yeah and then I go oh god it's up
the biggest rock I've ever seen I'm and
just hurled it through my window and the
thing just goes [ __ ] animal yeah you
[ __ ] animal now I had to get the
window fixed did I know yeah I don't
even think I remembered it is like good
[ __ ] god I was joking yeah we were up
member how the heck yeah yeah yeah the
Avalanche was a bar on wells and then
above it was kind of a flophouse right
was all some of the land yeah and then
there was an apartment and then the one
of the boozy owned the apartment that
had its own bathroom the other ones were
calling remember this yeah it was a
place of like when you got our prison
you go yeah yeah yeah you know you were
doing some parties up that is what
Brooks goes today yeah so we went up
there one time my brother used to live
then I think at the time it was like
Putin wags and those guys and we're
downstairs the at the at the land chris
is like it's cool upstairs all right to
grab like a case remember them a little
to go area so we go that and we went
like 9 feet and went upstairs and we're
just sitting there and we're all kind of
playing and somebody I don't know who
was riding or somebody had like a water
balloon it was kind of couple guys and
just threw a water balloon down Adam its
kind of guy okay anyway they were like
townies and it was the wrong town he's
the guy just turn I'm just like I'll be
back and I was like oh serious anyways
and he ran like a pickup truck and came
back like four minutes later with like
six other pickup truck no just started
whipping bottle he whipped a bottle and
I could above the thing were like oh
crap guys and they were man they reckon
this thing and then I think was good
Chris was like yeah this will scare him
there was a bowling ball like a walkie
but still there's a random bowling ball
so Chris gave it to somebody he goes
yeah this would be great we'll throw it
and so there was an open win
no there were three windows oh i thought
i was riding but he ran he had it and he
starts running and it takes it any
through it and he threw it wide and so
it just shattered the other window is
not open like he went like on upside arm
that one's going how's that and they
trigger these guys to be like i could
just put bottles it was like it was in a
war like sweet take cover god yes Oh
anywhere this was like a minute roommate
Kate like one of them came home like
what's going on like how do you explain
that was my bowling ball look a little
bit okay maybe he's cool I'm totally
cool my god but that's the [ __ ] that
mean in the land people don't know this
i mean now people that are there now at
marquette such a nice nice school it is
is very beautiful school but back in the
latch in the day they would serve red
white and blues and there were fifty
cents and when you got done with your
red white and blue there was a wall at
the end of the bar and you were supposed
to throw your glass against the wall and
the partner what he blinked an eye when
i first saw this I thought well the
bartender is gonna freakin right no no
you just know everybody you'd get done
with your book here red white and blue
and her lit girls would do it they'd all
hurl it against the back wall and be
shards of glass on the freaking back
wall you'd be like what yeah it made
knows the worst tradition you could ever
have oh my gosh Amy hi I'm a freshman
too what's going on is it with a bottle
in the temple really my friend was hit
with a pizza it was such a violent bar
such a crazy violent bar that everybody
went to yes fifty cents fifty cents for
and you got hung over from that [ __ ] oh
yeah tough stuff but it was just like
eating pit I remember like somebody
would get like bush and it was 60s
Angela what's up rockefeller yeah it is
so rise it like who's what's with a/c
mcGirk over here
it was so if you dared not get all red
white blue yeah at the lamps you were
not you're like um I'll have a miller
lite you know what what you guys have
any sense to throw ya hotshot hey
hotshot yeah and then there'd be fights
in that place every single night you
know i mean it was great i love the
Lance they took it out clean all that
[ __ ] up in mark yet clean all that up no
Marquette did a great job it's a great I
mean when I went there I mean I really
enjoyed Emma clear i like the stuff we
did and it's come an amazing amount from
that and it's a i try to get both my
kids to go there it's an amazing school
yeah i mean ultimately the kids nowadays
probably like the weather is probably
tough on them and all that yeah that's
the thing yeah coming from here to go
there it's pretty ohio yeah coming from
here more time for time uh i think it
was Chris in queens and i walking too oh
shoot the harp what was that underneath
the knights of columbus building that
was the river ya know the river yeah I
be highway know by the highway harpaz oh
go there the rain tree no no uh lose by
the highways Irish wasn't glocca Morra
o'donoghue's know now it was so instead
of going haggerty's oh I forget the name
of it but we went there I thought it was
just the harp cuz then there was a
harbin shamrock mmm of the thing but we
went there and it was so cold I mean
like you know we're like hey that's a
half block away we should each make sure
we get a can of beer for the walk to go
through the super bowl at a bar they're
gonna have plenty of beer I guess we're
walking and i'll hit this it was
februari so was negative 107 super cold
and queens took a sip and you hear this
weird sound and his lip stuck to the
green oh oh and i kid you not go Chris
and I both turned like which one of us
is gonna waste beer to get you out of
this like like we knew we had
but we're like well great now this
affects us and now I'm gonna have one
last set on the way to go drink because
so but I remember their faces were like
well I guess you gotta do it weights
might be right yes exactly I've heard of
heroes before oh man but yeah we had a
pour it over his neck get him free I
know we broke free yeah that's a [ __ ]
call that we get it was it was freezing
yeah praising call and then you know
they had these houses that had the wind
the wind would just hear us thinners
house at marquette was legendary because
it was not really a house I mean let's
not let's not call it a house no I mean
that really it was I mean you guys got
actually condemned right we would seem
sad it was a six-bedroom house yeah and
um we were condemned I think in a play
we had a um my wife died I gave me a dog
an Alaskan Husky which is a beautiful
dog and um I never had a dog so I don't
know how it works we went to costco and
got a giant thing and we just kind of
made a big leg trough that gets what
Damon would eat at the red you know kind
of a grazing dog which is great and we
had a party and I remember we had the
staircase the one up like kind of
halfway and they went out the other half
right and wags when time was slags an
enormous guy really talking to somebody
and his back was to the staircase and
then he laughed loud like he always does
and he leaned back and you heard this I
just a snap of English such an old house
and obviously condemn so they were doing
a lot of repairs and cracked and then he
fell all the way down into and he broke
it was a Kish Kish Kish Kish broke like
five steps like in it like remember the
addams family were spot you yeah it was
like that but the real estate so i'm
going to bed it was just like you like
literally just take two steps and then
go up it was like going like you had to
go over five more steps that worth it
was just as empty abyss that nobody was
down there and nobody i think we put a
cone down there to alert that there
possibly to do some safety issue you
would have parties with people come over
and they'd be like um there's a
all right here's steps guys and you're
like oh yeah jump over it we had parties
cuz we had no heat and when we died we
wanted people to be bottled its body
right so we did that sir but then what
about that's exactly what about right
tell us about Larry Hill coming home at
night Larry Hill well this house had no
um there's no bathroom door you kind of
leaned like a like a makeshift like
ironing board against it to give you
some sort of privacy I remember it's
Larry Hill dear friend of mine amazing
guy no it's your favorite things Larry
did we lived upstairs and Larry goes and
I got an idea we're quite good you know
how we never have much hot water as a
Gaddy go well I'm gonna take a nice cold
shower so then when I get out I'll be a
hot which in theory if you're for or
cartoons would make sense but but so he
would take a shower in the morning that
has like I shot my paw paw just reading
because and then it would never work
because now I did it like six or seven
ever never worn every but so Larry came
home we do a bar one time and he goes I
hey guys house meeting mhmmm where we've
never had a house meeting amazing and he
goes all gonna get some beer like this
is this is the great we should have
house meetings daily and so he came home
and we're all sitting on kind of various
couches and we brings puts down like a
case of beer and there was like a table
and he throws down like twenty condoms
and when I what are we gonna do yep here
I mean you knock the dirt and he goes
hey guys uh wanna let you know I'm out
like what do mean you're out he goes I
Patti and I or got a kid I got a kid on
the way grabbing a kid and you're yeah
18 19 yo yeah that was pretty big deal
it wasn't he goes uh he goes yeah see
you guys yeah you guys can have these
easier I mean I remember kind of going
to me it was given update do they not
work but why are you doing you're having
a child add them right and you've got 20
clearly enough for a night if not to I'm
confused on a gift
he was giving you guys the condoms yeah
so i'ma get it was such an article oh my
god oh yeah great guy what about me just
one more story about didn't he break the
window every night when he came home
Larry instead of going through the door
he would break the wind yes until you'd
break yea yea though you'd be like Larry
the door is open right and we never have
to me yeah yeah you just don't want you
know people thinking it's open mike so
you alert the neighborhood by shattering
a random window thus bringing the
negative 107 degree weather inside like
the Alaskan Husky is shivering oh you
know so and then I had a guy whose
bedroom above there watching TV in this
bedroom I think is better oh yeah I was
coming down I think he was gonna come
through the ceiling they had a whole
like in their bedroom like so you can
see the first floor and there are
certain things you're like aw it's kind
of cool because you can throw it on your
laundry and random but like again make
[ __ ] man you're kind of like hey what's
to say that it's not gonna I played you
know icebreaker I know what's gonna
happen this is gradually gonna be a
bigger and bigger bigger it's gonna get
bigger but yeah it was a crazy we had
that house is honoring it was not real
remember when do we had a dining room
with nothing in it because we had no
dining utensils and we had a couple of
cones that were ever mentioned yeah and
I tell it was a ball and a bat and a
member just kind of just kind of bunting
it off this thing one day and then he's
in my mind I'm just like what's the
worst thing that can happen I just haul
off and hit one and so it would hold off
and it hit the wall and it was plaster
so it just embedded this perfect thing
stop and then it would just kind of
slowly drop and then roll back to you
I'm like this is the greatest like game
and then we would have liked we drop
people like try to hit him in the head
or try to hit his hand are we drawing a
cow I hit the cow and we just and then
just like somebody walking about it hey
do you guys get that engineering
notebook with what do you guys do it we
still kind of an apathy isn't this
finals week he's like whoa
where's my game yeah every invention oh
oh my god padded no fun that was fine if
you like all these stories make sure you
check out i am chris farley wear pads an
amazing cook yeah thank you for helping
out with that inner that was nice no
it's really special I was uh yeah I was
telling somebody the other day that
they'd never heard so many of those
stories I'm like it's so great to be
able to tell those stories it's so sad
that he's not here to make more but I'll
tell you I actually had somebody at the
premiere of it which again is very
Hollywood at the premiere um the
bartender this girl and I've had
subsequently had like three or four
people come up and say that movie helped
them that change their lives she goes I
went in and watch that movie and she
goes yeah I just got closure from
something I just went through oh yeah
she goes wow just changed my life and
I'm while there we go why I mean that's
how quick it was and yeah that's kind of
like something out of that yeah what
what I was trying to do is is we all
know the other side I want to tell the
the side that hasn't been told what is
his what a unique caddy was you know and
so that's what that's what you get when
you watch the film and then you did a
great job just the through in the
beginning kind of bringing everybody
rain yeah the home movies and the rest
of you said Jan everybody everyone I do
you think it tells you a story of who he
was it does yeah I mean that's a really
I think you come away with is is I
remember I've worked with people that
have worked with John Candy I know I
gotta go sorry no and I never got the
pleasure of working with him but I've
always been a huge fan and subsequent
needs kind of like that with Chris that
there's so many people that are like
almost doe-eyed like what was he like
yes this is a way to say this is what he
was like thats I say for the rest of my
life I'll say just watch that
documentary and you'll get a really good
idea yeah it was you're right that's
a--that's special I think I'm your part
Kevin to have that had the vision but
then actually have it executed like I
mean you had t that does a lot for those
guys to that you work together really
well but yeah you're right i mean but it
also helps us to say he's right a lot of
people say what was he like what was
right just that's exactly what he was
like right there yeah that's exactly
what it was I'm sorry and Pat you are
currently recurring on the middle what
else is going on I am
your shark mice i follow yes oh nice
cool yeah we did how was Chicago really
calmed that part was a made such a great
place for him profits like doing jazz
and go back to New Orleans not that I do
jazz but but it's like it's like a mecca
for it so people there we did it at the
at the IAO theater in Chicago which is
an amazing place in Sharn has done such
an amazing job there and they had four
shows that were sold out so they had
another one it's sold out and people
went crazy for do you guys have a blast
we did yes it was really five really
great shows you get to saying the
seventh inning site up guys who's really
cool no it looked like you guys had a
blast what Chicago like slashes art it's
for you right ah wait I gotta go back
cause that don't happen no it wasn't a
covey game well oh by the way do you do
that even though the podcast and still
no not show them but it's no use you
don't know what it looks like when a
girl is that sure I'll hope you'll help
me with that I could wrong Pat thank you
so much are you on facebook twitter i am
yeah i'm on twitter it's at fat pad Finn
that's right and ok their shark mine
please come back we'd love to yeah go
back any time dead sitting in a bar and
hannah know exactly let's say I'm will
get beer yeah let's do it uh all right
well thank you so much god thanks so
much all things company and our producer
you'll see you soon bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye